Theodore Visnic and Adorno was born in
Frankfurt in 1903 into a wealthy and
cultured family his father a wine
merchant was of Jewish origin but had
converted to Protestantism at university
until his 20s Adorno planned for a
career as a composer but eventually
focused on philosophy in 1934 he was
barred on racial grounds from teaching
in Germany so he moved to Oxford and
later to New York and then Los Angeles
he was both fascinated and repelled by
Californian consumer culture and thought
with unusual depth about Sun tans and
drive-ins Adorno was closely connected
with a pioneering Institute of Social
Research also known as the Frankfurt
School which had been founded and funded
by his friend Felix vile the Institute
aimed to develop a psychological
understanding of the problems thrown up
by modern capitalism especially the
culture and mindset it generates Adorno
drew attention to three significant ways
in which capitalism corrupts and
degrades us
believe that the primary focus for
progressive philosophers should be the
study of how the working and middle
classes of developed nations think and
feel and in particular the manner in
which they spend their evenings and
weekends
Adorno had a highly ambitious view of
what leisure time should be for it was
not to relax and take one's mind off
things free time should be our prime
opportunity to expand and develop
ourselves to reach after our better
nature and to acquire the tools with
which to change society it's a time when
we might see films that can help us to
understand our relationships with new
clarity or read books that give us fresh
insights into politics or listen to
music that gives us courage to reform
ourselves and collective life but in the
modern world
add or no boom owned that leisure has
fallen into the hands of an omnipresent
and deeply malevolent entertainment
machine which he called the culture
industry modern films TV radio magazines
and now social media seemed for Adorno
to be almost designed to keep us
distracted unable to understand
ourselves and without the will to alter
political reality so for example the
news will feed us a mixture of salacious
nonsense and political stories that
scramble any possibility of
understanding the open prison within
which we exist the cinema shows us the
adventures of an alien invasion while
the real calamities of our world go
unattended pop music focuses
relentlessly on the emotions around
romantic love suggesting that happiness
can only come from meeting one very
special person rather than awakening us
to the pleasures of community and of a
more broadly distributed human sympathy
we wander through museum galleries
privately unsure what they really mean
and why we should care the culture
industry likes to keep us like that
distracted pliant confused and a bit
intimidated Adorno perceptively
described Walt Disney as the most
dangerous man in America
because of the huge range of consumer
it's available in modern capitalism we
naturally suppose that everything we
could possibly want is available the
only problem if there is one is that we
can't afford it but Adorno pointed out
that our real wants are carefully
shielded from us by capitalist industry
so that we end up forgetting what it is
we truly need and settle instead for
desires manufactured for us by
corporations without any interest in our
true welfare though we think we live in
a world of Plenty what we really require
to thrive namely tenderness
understanding calm insight community all
these things are in painfully short
supply and are utterly disconnected from
the present economy when they're trying
to sell us something
advertisers show us the thing that we
really want and then connect it to
something we don't actually need so we
can see an advert showing a group of
friends walking on a beach chatting
amiably or family having a picnic and
laughing warmly together these adverts
show us these things because they know
we crave community and connection but
the industrial economy prefers to keep
us lonely and consuming so at the end of
the adverts we'll be urged to buy some
25 year old whiskey or a car so powerful
that no road would ever let us legally
drive it at top speed
Adorno was writing at the dawn of the
age of the psychological questionnaire
these were widely in use in the United
States where they were measuring
consumer attitudes and commercial
behavior Adorno was intrigued by the
underlying concept of the questionnaire
and so together with colleagues devoted
himself to designing a rather different
kind of questionnaire one designed to
spot fascists the questionnaire that he
designed asked contributors to assess
their level of agreement with statements
like obedience and respect for authority
are the most important virtues children
should learn and if people would talk
less and work more everybody would be
better off and when a person has a
problem or worry it's best for him not
to think about it but to keep busy with
more cheerful things given the traumas
Germany had just been through it's no
surprise that Adorno gave his
questionnaire and what he called the F
scale fascist scale such attention his
team even sent the F scale to every
school in West Germany but a more widely
applicable lesson to be drawn from this
experiment is that psychology comes
ahead of politics long before someone is
racist homophobic or authoritarian they
are Adorno skillfully suggested likely
to be suffering from psychological
frailties and immaturity z' which is the
task of a good society to get better at
spotting and responding to rather than
leaving problems to fester so long that
there's eventually no way to deal with
them other than through force we should
learn to understand the psychology of
everyday insanity from the earliest
moments Adorno was a left-wing thinker
who recognized that the primary
obstacles the social progress are
cultural and psychological rather than
narrowly political or economic we
already have the money the resources
that time and the skills to make sure
that everyone can sleep in a house stop
destroying the planet it's given a
fulfilling job and feel supported by the
community so the reason why we continue
to suffer and hurt one another is first
and foremost because our minds are sick
this is the continuing provocation
offered by the beguiling
and calmly furious work of Theodor
Adorno
thank you so much for watching if you
like the videos we produce at the School
of Life then may we suggest you visit
our friends over at a channel called
wisecrack they to create wonderful
videos about philosophy literature
cinema psychology and more all with the
cheeky twist so click here to visit
their channel and we highly suggest that
you subscribe you might be especially
interested in their show called 8-bit
philosophy click here to watch their
classic episode on Plato's allegory of
the cave as explained through the video
game Zelda